I purchased the Rebuilder, so understand for those who don't know the Rebuilder is a medical tool which is this kind of a type of an electric stem that stimulates at the very specific frequency to stimulate neurogenesis, neurohealing.
And it's approved by the FDA. It's a nice tool. It's worked quite well over the years. It's been out for probably 15 years now.
I purchased the Rebuilder and I'm not sure I've used it correctly. I have water in both sides of a divided container. That's correct.
I insert one of the pads, the rubber pads on each side, then turn on the device with having one foot in each side of the container.
I'm afraid to turn it up too high. How do I know if the nerves are being properly stimulated? I also run it with my hands on either side. My neuropathy has gotten quite bad.
So how high you turn it up is to your ability to tolerate it with the reason I know some guys are like, I'm just taking it to give you all you can.
The more you do, the more you do, it's not necessarily better. But you need to feel a very strong tingle. So you want to feel a very strong tingle, but not uncomfortable.
That's the rule of the game. Nice strong tingle, but not so strong that it's like this is hurts. This is uncomfortable.
It's recommended by the company that you do it 30 minutes a day. However, I know the owner of the company I've been to his seminars. I've spoken to him personally.
And really all the research shows you really 15 minutes a day or if you did 15 minutes twice a day, you'd actually do better than 30 minutes once a day.
Well, what about the neuropathy? What if it's getting worse? You just need to keep doing it neuropathy. So I do have a video if you go to our blog post neuropathy.
I have several blog posts on neuropathy and I think I actually have this video on the store site for the rebuild or two where I talk about e-ferrant versus a-ferrant nerves.
I think that's beneficial. It's a little heavy, but it's beneficial to understand the pathways because when you understand how your body is rebuilding the nerves when you have neuropathy,
you do have to kind of go through sometimes a worsening before it gets better. So if your neuropathy has gotten so bad where you have no feeling in your feet,
we have a number of people who will buy the rebuild that aren't necessarily patients that they lost the feeling to their feet and understand a diabetic neuropathy is very common.
Now this person who asked this question may be suffering from diabetic neuropathy or a combination thereof with chemotherapy induced neuropathy, but either way high blood sugars or chemotherapy can destroy the peripheral nerves.
And then those nerves have to rebuild. Now the large diameter afference, that's the technical name for the first nerve that's destroyed, is has to rebuild the large diameter afference carry pain and tingling back to the brain.
So when you're re-stimulating those, you may experience an increase in pain and tingling. Keep doing it. If that will start to calm down and you'll start to get your feeling back.
So watch, try to watch that video. I know I think I have some other videos of just answering questions on neuropathy. But watch the video where I'm live talking about a-ferrant versus e-ferrant neural pathways. And I think that will help.
Don't give up. This is the best way the rebuilder is the best way to help a person with their neuropathy just bar none.